but making a decision as to what we do
with respect to the horrible attack that
was made near Damascus and it will be
met and it will be met forcefully and
when I will not say because I don't like
talking about timing
all right the president earlier tonight
during a meeting with military leaders
at the White House discussing how to
respond to the latest chemical attacks
in Syria that has now left at least 40
dead here with reaction
Sontaran policy group vice president
retired CIA senior intelligence officer
Daniel Hoffman former deputy assistant
to the president Fox News national
security strategists dr. Gorka mr.
Hoffman let me start with you you
understand this region from what I
understand you've worked there quite a
long period of time I did I was chief of
the CIA's Middle East operations for a
few years from 2010 to 14 and we
delivered pretty stark assessment to the
Obama administration about how Syria
would be transformed really into a petri
dish of threats to our national security
and we're seeing that play out where
Russia and Iran and Syria really have
this sort of axis of evil together
targeting innocent civilians and the
opposition Russia claims to be their to
fighting to fight Isis but that's really
not their purpose at all yeah well
that's a good point
do you believe that this was the Assad
regime and weren't they supposed to get
rid of those weapons they were it was
absolutely the Assad regime they've been
they've they've allegedly launched at
least eight chemical weapons attacks
this year using sarin and chlorine they
were supposed to have eliminated their
stockpiles back in June of 2014 by the
agreement that you highlighted earlier
and of course as we know that the Assad
regime isn't going to be held to those
sorts of agreements and they kept
certainly enough chemical weapons to
launch these sorts of attacks and and we
really need to make them pay for it but
we also need to make Russia and Iran pay
for it because those are the two
countries that are enabling Syria
ultimately in their in their tactical
and strategic objectives dr. Gork oh
let's get your take on this I thought I
heard the president say we probably know
after the fact almost something
it's a certainty I would not blame him
he did act before when the similar
circumstances arose in' in 2017 look if
we don't send a very clear message that
this cannot be done again others will
use chemical weapons we have
international taboos international
treaties Russia broke one during the
Obama administration by invading another
country and taking its territory for
itself that administration did
practically nothing now we have chemical
weapons used against women and children
the president I guarantee you in the
next 24 hours 48 hours will send a very
strong message as mr. Hoffman said not
just to Assad but to his sponsors and
his backers to Russia to Iran even to
China and North Korea that would ever
think about using these weapons against
innocent civilians about 2003 this isn't
about invasion this is about chemical
weapons use but the nexus between
politics and national security is
intersecting tonight and I even know
that there are people on NBC News that
have suggested even though the president
announced long before any news about
Michael Cohen that he would make a
decision within 24 to 48 hours they've
actually used the term on conspiracy TV
NBC wagged the dog it's reprehensible
represent the same people who say that
this administration is colluding with
Russia and that the president works of
Vladimir Putin went for the last 15
months every single significant policy
decision coming out of the Oval Office
with regards to Russia has been bad for
that KGB office of Vladimir Putin
whether it's the XL pipeline arming
Ukrainians increases increasing our
defense budget all of it
they live in a fantasy and you know what
at the end of the day their political
correctness undermines our national
security because we have to look at
these issues clinically unemotionally
and through a lens that looks at it as
if it is reality you know not some kind
of you know echo chamber like Ben Rhodes
was proud of remember the echo chamber
you know mr. Hoffman D I agree with the
president
and as much as we can't be the world's
policeman there are circumstances I
don't think America can fight wars
anymore after the experience in Iraq
where it becomes politicized after
thousands of Americans give their lives
and limbs Oh Washington decides never
mind we don't fight Wars to win them we
put ridiculous rules of engagement on
our brave men and women we're deciding
in Washington not on the ground what to
do same thing happened in Vietnam we
lost lost 58,000 people but there are
certain moments where it's only the
United States are we gonna sit back do
we have a moral obligation when we see
images of women and children being
gassed to stop it and prevent it we do
we've got a moral obligation absolutely
that's a violation of international
norms and and we do need to take action
we also have a strategic requirement to
de - to support our allies in the region
Israel Jordan and Lebanon not to mention
Europe which has been impacted so
severely by the migration crisis all the
inaction from the previous years really
resulted in the massive level of threats
to our national security and I think
what the administration is probably
thinking about on John Bolton's first
day is what are our options one of them
certainly is to launch at an attack on
an Syrian air base and I think we'll do
that but secondly do we set up safe
zones for the population and third would
we go even farther and resume assisting
arming anti-assad opposition so we have
a little more skin what you're saying
you know Russia what about them saying
all they didn't do it yeah that's I
watched the Russian News Sean and I
watch it every day and that's what they
called it false chief cup you know false
news that's what they do you know they
denied that they that they've used the
nerve agent against their gays could
Apollo the defector I don't you know
their population might believe that
stuff but we've got to hold them
accountable as well